thirty years ago today the Berlin Wall
one of the most enduring symbols of the
Cold War in Europe came down piece by
piece it was a pivotal moment the wall
divided the city between the Communist
East and the free West during the three
decades that it stood several world
leaders including former presidents
Kennedy and Reagan called on the Soviets
to tear it down Roxana Saberi reports
these flowers in the fragments of the
Berlin Wall marked 30 years since the
symbol of the split between communism
and democracy began to crumble built by
Soviet allied East Germany in 1961 the
wall began as barbed wire going up
overnight people in East Berlin woke up
to learn they were trapped over the
years thousands tried to breach the
27-mile wall for dozens of them the
attempt across the so-called death strip
guarded by soldiers and filled with
mines proved deadly John F Kennedy
visited the wall in 1963 paying tribute
to Berliners quest for freedom in 1987
Ronald Reagan followed with a message
for Soviet leader Mikhail Gorbachev mr.
Gorbachev tear down this wall two years
later that people did crowds on the
eastern side of the wall demanded they
be let through over whelmed border
guards had no choice but to step back
now their job is stamping passports as
fast as they can to keep the flow to the
West moving and many of them seemed to
relish their new role and that's good
the fall of the Berlin Wall pointed to
the end of the Cold War and the promise
of a more unified Democratic world but
three decades later that expectation has
faded with the rise of nationalism and
cracks appearing in the European Union
and NATO in Berlin yesterday Secretary
of State Mike Pompeo called on NATO
nations to spend more on their defence
he also criticized Russia and China
today
is just a stone's throw away it's rising
and if if we're honest it never really
went away completely and today German
Chancellor Angela Merkel urged Europe to
defend freedom and democracy warning
they should never be taken for granted
for CBS this morning Saturday Roxana
Saberi London